well people look who's back me hey it's
the neatest star right stargazer ain't
dead we were going through a breakup but
we decided you know what we can still be
friends and make this 40 we did this
everyone can something that we're dating
now yeah we're not we're not dating
we're just friends
occasional benefits Hey all the time I'm
a little bit um high right now we can
say that on that home yeah it's legal
and I intentionally got high how I've
done some videos prior to this kind of
video cuz it turn out to laughs a
difficulty Gregory I won't even grin oh
yeah I won't even smile
[ __ ] that's oh did I just do monetize
this video bears who cares at this point
even if the video is monetized it
wouldn't matter people actually good
point nothing matters it dick the one
hey no one we know you alright no
smiling oh you were me - alright talk
[ __ ] okay sorry see that mouth of the
Sailor comes just I have so many fingers
in my mouth Oh hahaha
this is why we like doing videos I am to
be here classic song
we play a game
[Music]
yeah just one complaint visit I see just
all these like the stains on it
we've seen it I because I target them to
you
[Applause]
damn car without cheating not believing
in it hey I think it's luck man
is that real burning yeah well the
traction you're just talking about this
a democratic state representative from
Manchester is under fire for apparently
posting a comment on Facebook that could
be deemed as insensitive towards the
Japanese heritage he wrote about a form
of Japanese cartoon skating anime is a
prime example of why 2 News just wasn't
enough a lot of Gina Alex on this very
next day they said my children coming at
supersonic speeds with some beloved or
without you assuming nothing more I
gotta get the room to be made a bit in
reverse you I turned to see the wing I
turn drop in just Dracula cool back drop
down said yeah big yeah would you say
Joey had sex with friends and guys you
never mentioned to him you suck this
date what something like very sick for a
while what is that anyway something like
36 and come with me
I'm 37
yeah 37 dips in a row
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
early but I guess we're doing us a sign
on the front of my house to take the
african-american short
did you notice the sign the front of my
house dead dead African American storage
no you know why you see that sign the
African Americans they might Rudy -
didn't bit holy I should thank God I
never maybe have been to see one of
those see thanks for the donuts down you
know the Krispy Kreme Serpico we need
your help every anime ever Oh Charlies
do it but it had done you know I was
going to say as we come in a bit
[Music]
[ __ ] pants down okay
Hobbit copy good hate that one song
[Music]
actually knocking on your doors a
million times you have to be
[Music]
if anyone ever called your name you
didn't like shirk quiet your [ __ ]
mood oh and this one time I came here I
took up my [ __ ] after 21 years you
never know what is gonna come through
that door
oh this is the toilet a couple of
airport
you wave your hand in front of the
center you wait for the fresh circle to
come around and now you're ready to use
it let me test it out right here and go
wave my hand and now you can see the
indicator thing going all the way around
and now I'm ready to take a huge [ __ ]
[Music]
applause any population and under very
two very specific circumstances
according to very it would be oh yeah
mule refrigerator Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yep take surrounds a great thing we have
one to go check out edik the ones
it's amazing he's got plenty to offer I
would say this is the first try not to
laugh challenge where I was able to
contain myself
I should be more mahai Oh more often I
believe that that is not the truth
because the one I did that I haven't
posted yet with you you're pretty
stellar good stuff well that one wasn't
that funny this one there were a couple
of really hard one not yeah first
daughter the Atome one where they
switched into dialogue from clerks of
latakia of him could learning from this
Girlfriends Past
how many guys she's blown that was
hilarious that went perfectly well with
it that's scene alone cracks me up but
seeing it to like an had an attainable
really rockin Ellis q so you said you've
been there before
it actually it was interesting to see
the anime linked up with that because if
you know I love anime I love Kevin Smith
movies so yeah and it doesn't matter the
girl's past that's the lesson I learned
no it shouldn't matter how many guys how
many blog dicks have it in her mouth or
a dick whichever a TA one how many a
dick the ones have been in her mouth
what a dick two dicks in her mouth but
if she is is if she's in love with you
and that would matter doesn't matter her
past journey or your past journey
there's no need to compare so what
matters is you two there you go I save
you guys a lot of future relationship I
mean this is really a relationship
every session that we're having I would
like the channel to more go into
relationship I feel like it would be you
know beneficial to go in that direction
like the fact that we managed to make
this breakup work and never be friends
you little devil
we're civil when we say friends but
we're definitely cool we make up for it
you know it's like we've all I sometimes
we haven't let it make up for it in just
37 dicks that we what did you know
anything out of my head I'm judging her
right now yeah when I said I've had died
there wasn't 37 that's that's way too
high of a number for me the number when
I had to comparison conversation with
someone
it wasn't 37 it was there was no way to
300 say it was way higher you had one
other dick in your mouth in my I had 37
yes
it doesn't matter all right there's a
thing called algorithm restrictor note
and fully conscious there's no need to
care at all what content you do that
earning doesn't matter a dick the one
every try not to laugh challenge I see
has a bunch of n-word jokes in them
definitely has to be like two to four
videos that are specific jokes about the
Edward yeah and but then even had a
really funny money I'll fiction I was
actually clever like the
african-americans like a politically
correct version yeah that was really
that was actually quite amusing so yeah
oh the Lincoln Park one with the dog
barking what's so cute hey that was no I
was I was I was laughing I was like yeah
I laugh I was like I was hot but I was
good I was definitely like my stomach
was going up and down yeah no I couldn't
not last throughout the whole thing and
you know in the beginning novel like X
what is it exile bayonet well it just
can't think and like what is that show
God that I watch that I like the fact
that it
dragged on so long that's what got me I
was just like okay effort sounds like
now I can just move and then at the end
of like just dragging on hard realize so
I can make it mount it eight is the one
you know humor and you also like racist
humor which is a very apparent
I think anything on the races I think
you might be on that note make sure the
ghost help support this channel by
checking out his patreon hey I'm in the
thumbnail what a bit hey you are oh damn
I have lost weight when I do my before
and after photo this is a screenshot
bringing so many generous like generous
comments generosity of your comment
generous giving uncommon that a good any
kind comment twenty out I but I don't
often notice it I was kind of noticing
before we filmed because it's a good
lighting in the mirror here and checking
yourself in myself Adams likely mix-up
that's what happens when I spoke before
video he's gonna look at myself and say
my name easel like American Psycho I
feel like in front of me I feel like
today I've been noticing like whoa I'm
getting some results that's good because
you you guys yeah thank you thank you
then she might actually get back
together I don't know yet loses too much
of the cushion for the pushin I might
not even consider it I am either cushion
for the pushin I like the cushion
because if you do the push I like
question no I'm the man I didn't say
wanna be true
hey subscribe to the real reject we
subscribe to the real rejects I need a
stargazer is on the Anita star channel
of the stargazer become a stargazer
night today and it's star-lord as well
as star-lord
ooh I love game of three oh I got it the
best for a second I forgot about
guardians of the galaxy here and I was
like I was like who is star-lord echidna
card it in uh and then Gaiman throat I
think if I saw the cheese it sounds very
[ __ ] be like at a gamer to us it could
be but it's not it's out of pretty yeah
make sure to check out our patreon so we
can keep not giving a [ __ ] about saying
whatever the [ __ ] we want an easy a few
videos this video might be blocked in
some countries who have no hold of the
countries so yeah so definitely support
the monkey tram because they're all and
you get benefits - yeah you get health
insurance just [ __ ] bring out a child
you know hi a better gifted - option
agent about the patreon ever